et rues de lagos vidées de leurs
voitures et de leurs habitants la
capitale économique du nigeria est entré
en confinement pour limiter la
propagation du virus
la mégapole de 20 millions d'habitants
est la plus grande ville d'afrique
imposer un confinement à autant de monde
semblait impossible
mais dans un pays encore marqué par
l'épidémie d'ebola en 2014
le président muhammadu buhari a pris des
mesures radicales ce dimanche sur la
base des conseils du ministère fédéral
de la santé et du ncdc j'ordonne la
cessation de tous les mouvements à les
gosses et au fct pour une période
initiale de 14 jours tous les citoyens
de ces régions doivent rester chez eux
les déplacements ou les voyages en
provenance d'autres états doivent être
reportés le confinement concerne aussi
la capitale abuja à l'annoncé de la
mesure les habitants se sont pressés sur
les routes créant des embouteillages
monstres à lagos les habitants ont fait
des provisions dans les marchés avant de
se cloîtrer chez eux
selon l'institut de recherche world
poverty clock 44% de la population
nigériane vit dans l'extrême pauvreté
nous ne sommes pas prêts car la
situation économique au nigeria n'est
pas vraiment bonne elle est très
mauvaise
les choses sont plus coûteuses qu'avant
nous avons seulement à ces deux choses à
la maison pour nous occuper de la
famille les deux semaines sont trop
longues
il n'y a pas assez d'argent pour que les
gens puissent prendre soin d'eux-mêmes
notent un enfant
ils nous ont demandé de rester à la
maison ils doivent nous fournir ce dont
nous avons besoin à l'intérieur de la
maison il n'y a pas de nourriture qu'on
nous vous voyez beaucoup de gens ici
mais ils n'ont pas d'argent pour acheter
de quoi se nourrir
il n'y a pas de nourriture stockée il
n'y a rien à manger dans la maison le
ghana l'afrique du sud et la côte
d'ivoire ont mis en place des mesures
similaires d'autres pays comme le bénin
ont choisi d'instaurer des cordon
sanitaire autour des grands foyers
urbains plutôt que d'ordonner le
confinement trop difficile à mettre en
place